(light music)
- I've been all over
this lake for 62 years.
Never seen nothing like this
has happened in my lifetime.
- [Man] Well, it's
certainly not our friend.
- Oh, they say it doubles in
size every four to five days.
- And it has real long
tentacles under the water.
- [Woman] It is literally a
monster that is overtaking
one of the most beautiful
places I've ever been.
(light music)
- [Man] The weevils are
the best bet because
it's nature fighting nature.
- If it wasn't for the weevils,
we'd be in bad trouble right now.
(light music)
(light water splashing)
- This is giant salvinia.
Scientists call it the world's worst weed.
On the surface it looks friendly enough.
It's bright green, fuzzy,
and it has small oval leaves.
But make no mistake, it is a lake killer.
- Giant salvinia is an
invasive species from Brazil,
that first appeared in Texas in 1998.
Under ideal conditions, it
can cover 40 square miles
in three months.
Boats can't drive through it,
native plants can't grow underneath it.
And fish and other wildlife
struggle to survive.
For twenty years we've
tried to get rid of it.
Somebody even tried to kill
it with a blowtorch once.
Today, we use an integrated
approach to manage salvinia,
including a very small and
unique insect from Brazil.
- By 2013, a group of
us became convinced that
weevils help promise to
combat giant salvinia.
So we organized a
grassroots effort to build
a weevil greenhouse here
in Uncertain, Texas.
- The main goal of the
greenhouse is to raise
a large army of weevils with
a diet of fresh salvinia.
And once their numbers
expand to a certain level,
then we'll take them out onto the lake.
I've never raised bugs before,
and I'm not an entomologist.
Everyone here is a volunteer,
and the reason we're
doing this is because we care about the lake.
Today, we have raised 350,000 weevils.
This is not an easy find, but
it's worth trying to do this.
They'll continue to do it,
I'll continue to do it,
and most people down
here will continue to do
what they can to save this lake.
(light music)
- We've had a few small areas of success.
I grew up here in Pine Island Pond,
and three years ago it
was covered in salvinia,
but since the release of the weevils,
we've seen slow, but dramatic change.
(light music)
- [Robert] Caddo Lake
is a unique treasure.
I've fallen in it, I've swam in it,
I've fished and hunted in it.
This lake has been part of
my soul for almost 50 years.
Fighting the salvinia is not an easy task.
It's not glamorous or flashy.
But the men and women who fight it
have no intention of losing.
And at the end of the day, we're
all in it for the long run.
(light music)